jean boulet avec nous bonsoir monsieur
ministre bons soins des étudiants
recommencer d'abord avec ce dossier dans
l'industrie alimentaire l'enjeu de main
d'oeuvre et est présent aussi chez
exceldor et chez olymel lui pea
les éleveurs de volailles les éleveurs
de porcs également son avis que les
abattoirs devraient être considérés
comme des services essentiels pour
éviter justement les arrêts de travail
coct monde en ce moment
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
m'a écoutée sur le fond pour en discuter
en mais si on regarde l'état du droit
actuel au québec
ce ne sont que les services publics ou
une obligation de mener des services
essentiels en cas de grave ici
évidemment ce n'est pas un service
public là c'est pas un hôpital une
résidence pour personnes année où une
entreprise de production d'énergie en
mettant ce que nos lois permettent c'est
que une partie plus demandé au tribunal
administratif du travail de considérer
comment un service assimilables à un
service paie blé et locle et servait sow
essentiels soient maintenues au-delà de
ça dans le dossier d'un excellent dans
natama la solution elle réside à la
table de négociations c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai nommé une médiatrice
spécial parce qu'on pouvait plus
accepter le gaspillage alimentaire un
découle l'euthanasie des poules est et
il ya des pourparlers qui se poursuivent
actuellement qui mangent encore bon
espoir que les parties vont exercer un
leadership est réglée rapidement
l'expert sylvain charlebois qu'on a été
rejouée dit qu'il y aura assurément
d'autres conflits de travail dans le
secteur parce que les conditions de
travail on le sait sont difficiles
les sallois les salaires sont inadéquat
et il ya une véritable prise de main
d'oeuvre aussi dans ce secteur c'est
quoi la solution de ce ministre mais
vous le mentionnez un yo pou yo pendant
de solution unique je pense qu'il faut
multiplier les efforts il faut que tous
les partenaires du marché du travail
contribue à ce qu'on puisse lutter
efficacement contre la rente ai mais
intervenant dans le domaine de la
transformation alimentaire a
sexuellement la paix de riz
particulièrement aiguë
y a des solutions les travailleurs
étrangers temporaires en font partie
l'intégration des clientèles qui sont un
peu puis loyers du marché du travail au
québec les femmes les jeunes les
personnes handicapées les bénéficiaires
des aides sociales il ya beaucoup de ces
clientèles là qui prétextent extrêmement
utile dans le contexte de pénurie
maintenant qui bien sûr quand je réfère
aux entreprises y aura des six de
numérisation d'augmentation de
productivité je sais que dans traces
dans le la transformation alimentaire
les employés font énormément d'efforts
pour ceux numérisés puisse avoir ça va
donner des bons résultats ce qui est de
l'argent pour ces gens là pour otomi
automatisé robotisée améliorer leur
productivité à monsieur fillion chi
tellement heureux que vous le donner
cette opportunité l'inde a précisé que à
mon ministère
on assume 85 % des frais de formation
des entreprises qui doivent réorganiser
leur travail pour augmenter la
productivité ou qui suite à
l'acquisition d'une technologie
numérique ont besoin de sommes énormes
et il se jouera ce que j'ai raison ceux
déjà beaucoup utilisé me boulet jusqu'à
maintenant
malheureusement seulement 2500
entreprises au québec sur à peu près 270
zinal en bénéficient de cette mesure là
il faut la faire connaître
- j'ai dit les entrepreneurs en un défi
majeur
nos processus d'affaires sont pas
suffisamment automatisés quand on se
compare à l'ontario aux états unis à
l'allemagne donc ce défi là on doit le
relever collectivement et c'est tous
ensemble soit n'ai aucune responsabilité
étatique
les entreprises doivent s'impliquer et
contribuer à améliorer la productivité
on a l'impression à chaque fois qu'on
parle justement de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
vous nous parlez formation vous nous
parlez d'automatisation et là le chiffre
que vous donner c'est qu'un emploi sur
cinq d'ici 10 ans sera comblé par
l'immigration
on a toujours l'impression en vous
parlant pia en parlant à votre
gouvernement que l'immigration ne fait
pas partie de la solution pourquoi c'est
ainsi
moi je vous dirais monsieur fillon
mongolie travailleurs expérimentés
veulent les personnes de 55 ans et plus
haut notre taux d'emploi baudelet les
sommes qu'ils ont perdu en grand nombre
leur emploi durant la pandémie et le
niveau de récupération de leur emploi
est encore un peu trop bon donc c'est un
potentiel intéressant les jeunes vont
combler 54 % de nos besoins dans les dix
prochaines années il y en a à peu près
200 milles sont ni en emploi ni aux
études ni en formation
il ya un potentiel immense qui ont
contribuer par l'on mesure à les
intégrer par la voix de subventions
salariales et d'autres programmes et les
personnes élégantes
vous avez raison cet interprète 20 2 %
des besoins que nous aurons à combler
dans les dix prochaines années on parle
d'à peu près 1.4 million de postes
vacants suite à des départs à la
retraite parce que utilement
c'est une crise démographique la
population vieillir beaucoup de départs
à la retraite de création de nouveaux
endroits en apprend des bras un train
des branches il ya un an au québec on a
encore près de 300000 personnes qui sont
en chômage
ça prend des brocs québécois et les
brand extérieur dans la mesure où les
personnes sont qualifiés sont en mesure
de répondre concrètement aux besoins de
nos entreprises
il faut que cette assemblée puisse no 1
des fous que je vous dise ou si monsieur
fillon à chaque acompte des
entrepreneurs au québec
la bcr faut pas sous-estimer sont en
effet des incitatifs pour le retour au
travail mais s'achève là elle va baisser
à la fin aux
et elle va se terminer à la fin du mois
de septembre donc évitons nos potentiels
québécois et les personnes immigrantes
qui ont les qualifications bien sûr ça
fait partie de nos actions
merci messieurs ministre est d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci monsieur fillion
à bientôt
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit